hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade also known as
Lord minion 777 say hi hi guys as you
may or may not have known we are
professional dancers and we're here to
dance the night away for you guys with
some fitness thrown in yes we are gonna
be workout warriors and dance
deliberated dance last absolutely said
wait here we go with more amazing stuff
and let me put ok go let me there we go
we got one no not the left hand right
hand okay now put yours up you got to do
like me man yeah there you know why I'm
Iron Man though that's pretty cool yes
okay all right excellent how this works
y'all ready to dance I'm so really nice
here I hope that my girl is fitting up
that motor hello yeah hey mr. K oh yeah
okay here we go we did this once to
practice oh just a little bit odd though
my man Dennis what do you mean your
manliness we're nothing but losing
manliness here yes oh here we go
OOP haha I hope you're actually trying
with this I don't know here stand front
very much put grueling oh and zooming
I'm zooming we have to make it
all song the Sun can't even see because
if you stamp sunglasses yeah okay
what papa ha ha yeah ha ha
we don't need to make those songs okay
all right this is where it got weird
doesn't work ok ok we know not that yoke
oh my god oh no this again
if we can just concentrate a little bit
not praying so damn much it never stops
ah ok back to normal first position
elegantly do the gazelle and then trains
about issues and then dance then dance
and be held in the middle huh ha ha ha
haaa again I don't know what how the
hama means but i think you did it we
don't be so perfectly oh yeah oh we
weren't supposed to copy mom you got 89
Christine I got 90 I did haba haba right
the one I know I know you didn't have a
hablar I gonna have to get your hobbits
right on the robotis don't [ __ ] up okay
we gotta prepare for the big show oh my
dress is doing it Oh what you [ __ ] get
it up there so sorry you're not uh Lexie
no oh I like the video that's cool that
is cool visit this one you guys are
seeing right now
gratulations wait you guys need to watch
the bonus video instead of our video it
would probably be better
Oh bad I can understand that back a
demon bat demon connect back go back
back go back shut up
Xbox go back what you asked our main man
sounds like a nice slow page it's our
main man jammy-jam room camera me okay
it's got to recognize you first
apparently because you or me
oh love me love me I think it does
please oh please want to get away get
away from Glory's connect oh there goes
it's almost there blue a little bit yeah
bring your fingers well [ __ ] oh not
[ __ ] me please
and now we shall dance the dance of our
people if you didn't know we're
full-blooded Russians vodka si Senor ah
yes I liked it oh sorry sir look at this
wonder well someone okay Oh Russians do
this every day
Masaru
love money for the people and you have
pigs
okay other people other people are the
Communist Party Oh God
the bed my weight I was doing safely
okay why not
it's normal you know tell we're all
explained okay never mind
so your only talk about it jump sickles
you can talk about things like not even
a little bit uh okay uh work what we're
dancing like if we could stop kicking oh
why do you say something worth uh Wow
huh oh gosh yes again you know drinking
vodka just gets you in shape like this I
don't think it does I think the Russian
people do this and drink vodka
so they die screw God so they don't have
to do the second-ever goddamn daddy
I hope and ya wanna [ __ ] me huh nice to
meet you haha I think my goodness just
traveled ten guys I think you deserve
you're gonna head out on the Emotiv
Russian oh I'm not rushing really good
nourishing ah rushing to get out of here
those are rinsed over cuz he missed
we're mister first Oh
that's good nice easy rules for this
next one we shall do our best to make
sure that we make intelligible
conversation that's not correct this is
my um is this five nights at freddys
business you never said that to me
before I just ordered this all right why
not why not we were gonna rush in and
Carman someone for Spanish money
oh crap I wasn't supposed to do this
carbon is Italian totally play my quest
Oh from the deep regions of
Czechoslovakia on our progress has been
that good I'll use it Ben all right I'm
not a dancer here's a bet okay too I
believe
oh hello heisting the lady have a honey
I think I'm wearing that top so thank
you very much okay here we really would
like work okay that I'm exit okay well
then oh my god I don't know Oh God
haunted trailer we got a performance to
do everyone is counting on us to win the
gold in the Olympic dance regimen Oh God
Zumba for the Lord is the backup day
it's okay okay well that's not Irish Cup
what in the world is I don't know okay
come at me bro you think you can deck
with me
Briana what the hell is wrong with you
let's pick a fight you should go away
okay here we go
yeah yeah I'll just get on okay we need
some iron changing again we need some
Guinness go down we bottle a badoom boom
with your brother huh oh yeah this again
you wanna fight brother or ma'am not
film in my eye
oh [ __ ] oh I can't talk right now oh
yeah well what's up yeah
step back yeah yeah yeah to the back
okay huh we're old yeah what MIT bar
once again I was you Charlie okay Oh God
I'm one high down drink kick look at the
Stars
oh gosh your kids yeah look I like this
okay I'm getting the pattern not really
good still it's only my I think it's so
long sweat okay one more time come on no
oh oh oh yeah I'll call you um we tied
we're gone we'll silver stars
I recorded immediately and staying in
the one where we go to listening to the
show
I want this sound good okay never works
done that was my back and not the couch
oh wow Chloe yeah thank you all so much
for enjoying our dance recital here this
was a stupid idea
I don't even know if I'm gonna post this
so anyway thank you also for watching
don't expect us to ever do this again
never and as always Oh check out weight
sales in the description
say hi Holly we'll see you in the next
video but ah we are both in your life
yeah okay yes oh ha ha
wait wait wait we all go okay all right
okay okay all right